all right the third story just because
it's so freaking bananas and shows you
how stupid the endless racialization of
everything is i had to do this story
uh major league baseball america's past
time people
it is going to invest 150 million
dollars to ensure that more black people
play
baseball we've got some quotes from espn
which used to be
a pretty decent sports network i don't
even know exactly what it is right now
except a 24-hour race palooza
major league baseball is committing up
to 150 million dollars to the players
alliance
a non-profit organization formed last
year
and composed of active and former major
league players aiming to build more
equitable systems in baseball and
increase
black representation throughout the
sport according to a monday news release
beginning in 2023 mlb will provide an
annual
10 million plus an additional 5 million
in matching contributions
from external players alliance
fundraising it represents the largest
financial commitment in mlb
history towards the goal of improving
diversity in sport on the field
in managerial coaching positions and in
front
office leadership so okay before we get
to breaking down
uh some of the stats related to how many
white people and black people and
hispanic people play baseball or
basketball or anything else
which is just so stupid in and of itself
before we do that i just want to say
something about
sports in general nobody cares what
color you are
in sports except this new
hyper-racialized woke
set of people i have played basketball
my whole life i've played baseball
i've watched sports my whole life as you
know i don't watch any current sports
anymore i watch old sports
but when you're playing a sport and when
you care about sport whether it's
track and field whether it's basketball
whether it's swimming
sports are the great equalizers it's the
ultimate meritocracy nobody cares if
you're a great athlete everybody loves
you
right like if you're a great athlete and
the best at what you do and you try the
hardest and play the hardest and you win
it's like nobody's running around caring
about
race nobody cared that magic johnson was
black
and larry bird was white if anything it
was sort of fun
there was a there was a sort of funness
between this white guy from indiana
and magic johnson showtime la right like
nobody cares nobody cares except these
people so now let's just break down
some numbers right now so in the major
league baseball by race
57.5 of the players are white 31.9
of the players are hispanic 7.7
are black and 2.9 percent are asian so
that's
that's pretty interesting and then i
said to my guys well let's get some
numbers i don't know what the ma the
racial breakdown of america is because i
don't really care about this stuff so i
said let's get the racial breakdown
of america and compare it to these
numbers so in america
60 of the people in america
are white now 57.5 of the major league
baseball players are white so actually
white people are underrepresented in
major league baseball so i assume
that somebody's going to start a
non-profit to up that to 2.5
right we got to get that 57.5 we got to
up that
2.5 percent get that to 60 so that white
people
are exactly 60 in society and exactly 60
in baseball because that's equity and
yeah
okay hispanic people man they are
crushing it
in major league baseball 31.9 percent of
major league baseball players
are hispanic but only 18 of americans
are hispanic so hispanics are
overrepresented by about 13
in baseball we've got to get rid of them
the same way we got rid
of asian people at harvard we must get
rid
of hispanic baseball players now i know
the media matters people that's the clip
you guys are gonna go for
enjoy it there you go you losers uh
black people okay so this is the
interesting one
black people 7.7 percent
of major league baseball players are
black 13 percent of americans
so it's off by you know a little less
than six percent about five and a half
percent or so right
now okay so black people are slightly
underrepresented does that seem like a
major problem
because that's is uh somebody stopping
black people from
playing baseball do black people
generally like basketball more i don't
know that's a general thought
but nobody's stopping them literally
nobody's stopping them like is there a
young
kid who is a great young black baseball
player
who is like crushing it right and then
the coaches
and the league is like ah we don't want
any more black people in this league
like it's just
sheer nonsense and then asians slash
other
so i don't know who qualifies as other
are
at 2.9 percent
now uh i thought we'd jump over to the
nba because basketball is my favorite
sport as you know and
and if baseball has a racial problem
then i i would suspect
that basketball would have an even
bigger racial problem
so white people make up only 16.9
of nba players now white people are 60
of america do the math people we got a
big
big problem we got about a 43 percentage
point problem over there
we've got to get more white people
in the nba i'm going to show you a video
of me on the basketball court in just a
moment
because it's time my dreams are about to
come true it's very exciting
hispanics are only 2.2 percent
of the nba but they're 18
of uh of all of america now they were
overrepresented in baseball so we'll
just that's a wash okay we'll just let
that be
and this one's a doozy this one's tough
black people
74.2 of the nba are black
and uh 13 of
uh america is black so they got about a
61 percentage point difference there
so we've got to lower the amount of
black people in the name of equity we're
going to have to
we'll just randomly select them you know
it's it's what we have to do